>> Announcer 1: POKED AWAY.
NICE
IT BACK TO THE
POINT.
2:  -- OBVIOUSLY
IF YOU CAN SHUT DOWN THAT
BERGERON LINE, YOU CAN RELY ON
SHOT KNOCKED DOWN BY PUZO.
NOT OUT. GOING.
>> Announcer 1: TURNOVER.
HOLUB REQUESTED.
PENALTY COMING.
SHOT LIGHTING UP IS CLICK THAN
AN ESSAY BY WHOSO BUT THE
COME OUT
AND THE BLUES WILL COME ON A
POWER-PLAY.
BARRANCO, THE RIGHT POINT OFF
THEY COME BACK TO THIS
BUILDING, TOREY KRUG WAS
DEVELOP AS IT IS HAPPENING
AHEAD OF EVERYBODY ELSE.
AND IT IS WHAT SEPARATES HIM
AND MACROSS.
NET FRONT.
WITHOUT EVEN LOOKING, HE CAN
SPIN AND THROW IT -- HE KNOWS
PERUNOVICH'S  28 CHEN, TRYING T
CAPTAINED BY COYLE BOSTON.
>> Announcer 2: SMART SHOPPER
IT.
LOOK AT THAT SAVE COMING ACROSS
WITH THE BLOCULD YOU
HANDLE IT WHEN YOU WENT HOME?
REBOUNDS AND OPPORTUNITIES IN
TIGHT.
>> Announcer 1: WE GOT
PHYSICALITY LATE IN THE FIRST-
WRAPAROUND CHANCE. N
FLIPPED IT UP AND NO.
THEY SAY NO CALL, AND NOW THEY
WILL STOP PLAY.
BOSTON THINKS THEY HAVE SCORED.
BERGERON IN THE NEUTRAL ZONE.
LADY.
PERUNOVICH.
TARASENKO AND IT A SHOT LOOKING
AROUND IT AT JUST
CREATING A LITTLE BIT OF FOR BO
DEFLECTION.
AND IT IS HERE COMES O'REILLY.
RACING THROUGH CENTER.
HITS THE BRAKES.
AND OFF THE SKATE OF SAAD .  IT
ON NET.
LONG STRETCH PASS FOR LAZAR.
IN FRONT. PASS IN
BACKHAND FOR THE ICE.
THOMAS OFF THE DEFLECTION.
TIES FROM THOMAS BEHIND HIS BOD
FOR.
BOSTON REALLY PLAYING A
DISCIPLINED GAME.
MARSH AND CUTTING  AND TURN
BARBASHEV.
KNOCKED AWAY BY COYLE. CRAIG BE
SOME DIFFERENT LOOKS ON THE ICE
CAN HOLD THE POINT.  WITH A BAC
AND,